pas de but pas de victoire sans le
soutien inconditionnel des supporters
derrière leurs équipes venues du monde
entier ils ont animé les stades où les
champs elysées encore images souvenirs
de ses supporters sélectionnés par daïc
audouit
je pouvoir
moi
on valide
pendant un mois paris a accueilli le
monde
cela avait bien commencé des
chippendales écossais déferlé sur la
capitale
la tartan army mêler ses couleurs rouge
jaune et vert du brésil
le parc des princes et le stade de
france pour fait le plein de spectateurs
mais dans les rues de paris il n'eut pas
l'ambiance souhaitée il s'attendait à
une vague de supporters ce que juste une
écume la faute pour moitié par payer
dans toute la france les supporters ne
sont que de passage
aussi pas de temps à perdre une seule
destination pour tous et champs elysées
avec à chaque fois des scènes de
fraternisation habituel quand la région
il n'y a pas eu de problèmes de violence
weeds parade des images souvenirs les
supporters écossais les meilleurs du
monde et les nigérians qui avant pendant
et après le match n'arrête pas de danse
et une chorégraphie qui n'égale pas
celle du supporters chiliens obtenant un
billet mais en fait il faut attendre la
victoire française en quarts et demi
finales pour que la folie fatale
vraiment un pari les images que l'on
espère voir encore ce soir même en cas
de défaite
à